donc en fait ici on est vraiment dans
l'atelier d'origine
c'est ici que finalement tout a commencé
d'ailleurs il ya des machines que vous
avez ici qui sont depuis l'origine donc
c'est le cas ici c'est encore ici qu'on
fabrique tous les cadres en acier
aujourd'hui on maîtrise trois matériaux
l'acier l'aluminium et le carbone sur
différentes pratiques mais c'est
vraiment dans cet environnement là que
vous ferez toujours des cadres acier qui
sont toujours très populaires
aymeric lebrun faisait du vélo avant de
parler un vrai passionné qui a repris 6
fac en 2010 on est toujours sur quelque
chose de très étiré très manuel très
artisanal aujourd'hui voilà là on est
sur un cadre chaque cadre est fabriqué
sur mesure sifac un nom mythique dans
les années 80 l'atelier kippa lors les
plus grands champions du tour de france
fignon virac pantani écrivent la légende
du cyclisme sur des cadres de la petite
entreprise tourangelle aujourd'hui les
vélos du tour sont fabriqués en chine
mais sifac reste une référence mondiale
pour la compétition en tandem
la fédération australienne qui nous a
commandé 200 m pour deux équipes
différentes
le couple féminin et le couple masculin
et c'est vrai qu'ils ont comme objectif
d'être champion du monde et non le même
logique objectifs avec eux et c'est vrai
que là où il ya des spécificités c'est
pour la piste donc ça va être des pâtes
à l'arrière qui sont très particulières
et puis on va surtout rigidifier au
maximum à la pointe de la technologie le
carbone titane et le kevlar
si vous regardez la scène par l'amp cela
on voit qu'ils déforment très facilement
donc on va pouvoir l'orienter et puis
jouer sur le confort là on est sur
quelque chose de plus rigide et puis là
on est sur du carbone et kevlar qui a
deux caractéristiques ils filtrent
parfaitement les vibrations et il est
quasiment destructive en fait et gilet
pare-balles s'est fait avec sa team
pétition le client peut choisir son
décor dans une palette de 30 mille
couleurs
chaque vélo est unique et celui ci a été
signé par l'équipe qui l'a conçu
l'atelier exporte un quart de sa
production dans le monde entier et le
label patrimoine vivant est un véritable
atout c'est aussi une reconnaissance à
l'international c'est quelque chose qui
nous a vraiment valorisé différencier
vis-à-vis de nos concurrents
et puis c'est aussi une exigence c'est à
dire qu'on a eu aujourd'hui on est fier
de ce label laquelle mais quelque part
on est un ambassadeur de ce label là et
ça exige de notre part bas de rester sur
nos valeurs d'excellence de sur mesure
et de savoir faire
[Musique]
ces vélos de course ou de randonnée sont
des bijoux de technologie vendue entre
cinq et quinze mille euros
[Musique]